- It's like you don't matter.
You don't exist.
You can be replaced.
It's the four Fs.
They find you, they
feed you, they fuck you
and then they forget you.
Sometimes it's just three.
Cause they might not feed you.
But they'll find you, they'll fuck you
and they damn sure will forget you.
- [Interviewer] All right, Trina.
Trina, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in Los Angeles
but I'm originally from Bellflower.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family,
had both your parents when you were young?
- Yes. I just recently lost my father.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- My childhood was good.
I didn't have to want for anything.
I pretty much got what I wanted.
I didn't start getting
into the streets until
I was about what, 18.
And coming to LA it was like a movie.
Stuff you see on TV.
So, I guess I got fascinated
with the street life,
with the hustle, with the fast money.
I had my ups, I had my downs.
I used to be a dancer.
So, dealing with men,
I call 'em TAV, Trick a Vic.
- [Interviewer] You call them what?
- Trick a Vic, TAV.
So basically, just trick
them off their money.
They think they're gonna get one thing
and they get nothing.
Sometimes they might get something
depending on what they're talking.
- [Interviewer] That's
why they're called tricks.
Yeah, Trick a Vic.
You trick a Vic.
You're a victim, you got tricked.
But yeah, when I was a dancer,
I knew how to-- I learned about basically,
you know what I'm saying?
Time is money and money is time.
And if you don't have no money
then I don't have no time for you.
- [Interviewer] When you say
dancer, you mean strip club?
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So, that's where basically,
the street life came in for me,
being out at the clubs to like
four o'clock in the morning.
(upbeat music)
So, I learned at a younger age.
Cause I started dancing when I was 17.
- [Interviewer] Is there something about
the culture that you grew up in
that makes that lifestyle
attractive to a young girl?
- I mean, I grew up in
the church and everything
so, I mean, I never would have
thought outside looking in
that I would be in the
streets like how I am.
I don't live on the street necessarily,
but just always running the streets.
I've always felt like you
never know who you can meet
or what you can come up
on, you know, networking.
- [Interviewer] What's
your best case scenario?
What's your dream of who
you might meet in that life
that entices you, like, you're hoping
that maybe a celebrity
might come into your life?
- I've dated celebrities before,
I've dealt with them before.
But this was when I was
like, when I was dancing.
I mean, basically
anybody who's financially
very financially stable.
- [Interviewer] Sugar daddy.
- Yeah.
- Regardless if it's a celebrity
or a regular person or, you know.
I honestly had doctors, lawyers,
I dated this lawyer and he
really didn't wanna have sex.
He had a wife and everything.
He just wanted to be dominated.
He liked dominatrix.
I used to wear patent leather
black boots, thigh highs.
And he would want me to wear
patent leather everything,
just whip him, whatever, just talk--
You know what I'm saying?
Just talk shit to him.
So, and he would pay me $1,500 every time.
And it was only for like maybe an hour.
- [Interviewer] Then you
guys would go to a hotel
or something like that?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] Motel?
- Yeah, we'd go to The Renaissance
or to The Marriott or to like
Sheraton, The Five Seasons.
Some, you know, so--
I mean that's quick money,
an hour, $1,500.
- [Interviewer] That's great money.
- Some people don't even
make that in a week.
- [Interviewer] What's
the downside of that?
- You know, you never know what type--
The mental level of a person,
some people can portray to be normal
but really have psychologic mental issues.
Someone can flip out on you,
attack you rape you, try to rob.
It's a lot of things that can go wrong.
Just as well there's a lot
of things that can go right.
You know, so--
- [Interviewer] You got ash on the floor.
- Oh!
- You can take a hit too, if you want.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] So, do
you recall your first,
the first guy who picked you up?
- To be honest, mm-mm.
- [Interviewer] You don't recall?
- Mm-mm.
- [Interviewer] But the typical--
- I mean, it wasn't nothing
memorable, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah. But
the typical interaction is
the guy comes, pulls his car up and--
- Pulls his car up, you
know, states what he wants
or says how much he has.
- [Interviewer] You
guys agree on something?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] Then you hop in the car.
- Yeah I hop in the car.
Sometimes I can sit there and take a hit
and just start wigging out.
Or I'll say, they'll ask,
"Do you have a condom?"
But I already have the money.
As soon as I get in the
car, I want the money.
- [Interviewer] You're
already paid upfront?
- Paid upfront.
I'm not gonna do too much talking.
You already said what you wanted,
you said what you're gonna give me
so give it to me.
Or I'll be like I have a condom in the car
or let me go around and get a condom
and I'll hop out and just leave.
- [Interviewer] So, typically
you would go to a hotel, motel
or something like that?
- No, I mean, I would leave
as in go off, by myself.
- [Interviewer] No, no, but if--
- But in, yeah, to a--
- [Interviewer] When it goes smoothly?
- Yeah, to a room.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I don't too much do cars.
- [Interviewer] And
you'll do the whole thing
in less than an hour?
- Less than 30 minutes.
- [Interviewer] Is that right?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] And do you do this
multiple times in a night?
- Mm-hmm.
Now how many times I really have
to be sexually active with them?
Maybe once or twice out of the--
Let's say if it's five
people it might be one,
or it might be none.
- [Interviewer] Really?
Or if it's out of 10 people,
it might be one or two.
It's all in your mouthpiece,
it's all in tricking a Vic.
You gotta trick them, sell them.
You know what I'm saying?
It's all about selling the
dream, selling the fantasy,
selling what they want.
- [Interviewer] And, and
you'll get out with--
you'll get some money and get out
without having sex by doing what?
- By being me.
- [Interviewer] By robbing them?
- No, by being me.
It's the game you have.
A lot of people level is different.
Like I said, I used to
work in the strip club.
Guys want my time.
Okay, time is money.
So, you wanna go to dinner?
Okay, you're gonna pay me to go to dinner,
pay for my dinner and pay for my gas.
I can take myself to dinner.
I don't need you to do that
so what benefit do I get
out of going to dinner with
you, giving you my time.
I could be somewhere else making money.
So I'm here.
So, what? Cause you're feeding?
That doesn't--
I can feed myself.
- [Interviewer] And what's
your general view of men?
Do you see them as people to
be taken advantage of, tricked?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All of them?
- Because I've had a lot of men trick me
or deceive me, manipulate me, betray me.
So, I just get them
for what they're worth.
And that's all they're
worth is their money, to me.
- [Interviewer] You ever
been in love before?
- I've thought I've been
in love, but you know,
a lot of times it turned
out to be a facade.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you?
- I just turned 35.
- [Interviewer] You're 35?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] And you work
for the pimp or without?
- I have a protector, Dragon.
See the necklace.
- [Interviewer] And how much
of your money do you give him?
- It depends on how much I make.
Cause I don't give it all
to him, but eventually all
you know what I'm saying?
Goes invests it.
And we've invested in each other.
So, that's why we don't look at each other
as pimps and hoes, we're partners,
business partners.
This is a business and we work together.
- [Interviewer] And how
much will you making
in a good night?
- I've made up to like 45 to five
in one night on a good night.
- [Interviewer] Almost $5,000.
- Especially when I used
to work at the club.
- [Interviewer] So, when
you're working at a strip club
you're also doing stuff on the side there.
- That's how you, I mean
I can network with people
like a lot of doctors and
like I said, lawyers go there.
So, I mean, it's a different type of crowd
from the people who just
driving down the street,
looking for somebody.
- [Interviewer] Right.
So, in a strip club, you'll do something
in the back room or you'll
go elsewhere after work?
- Meet them after the club.
Now if they pay me worth
my time of leaving,
like one guy who paid me,
I think it was like $800,
between $800 to a $1,000 to leave.
So, it depends on how the night is.
If I feel like I can make
more than that at the club
I'll stay there and just tell
them I'll meet you afterwards.
But if it's a slow night and they app--
Then I'll go.
I'll go, sometimes I'll come back.
- [Interviewer] And are
drugs a part of your life?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] What drug is that?
- Cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Crack or cocaine?
- Both and weed.
- [Interviewer] And when
did you start with cocaine?
- Cause I just started dating
males at the age of 30.
I was dating females, majority of my life
and the last woman I was
in a relationship with,
she's the one who turned me onto it.
She tried to use the drug
to control me, you know.
She manipulated me with it.
So, yeah.
So, love is what got me started,
trust is what got me started.
- [Interviewer] Do you
see relationships with men
different than relationships with females?
- Yes and no.
The drama, the bullshit,
it's all the same in all relationships,
but the intimacy, the catering,
the compassion is very much different.
Females know how to tend to other females
because they know how
they wanna be tended to.
- [Interviewer] Does your
family know you're doing this?
- My family knows I've danced.
They know I use drugs.
I recently went to a drug rehab.
I was there for seven months
when I got out, it's like $170.
And once again, love was what
brought me back out here.
The person I was dating at the time,
fed me this dream that
they're gonna change,
they're proud of me,
like I wanna quit blah blah blah.
And a couple of days after I get out
he was calling me like, I wanna see you,
I miss you, blah blah blah.
So I go to see him.
And the first thing he tells
me is you got some money?
Let's go to the spot.
So basically, all you wanted
me to do is come out here
to support your habit.
And like a fool I came out here,
I could have said no, but
you know, the temptation,
the add--
It's difficult, it's hard.
And a person won't know that
unless they've been through it.
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No kids.
You ever get down?
Do you ever get depressed
with this lifestyle?
- Yes.
I've had many breakdowns.
Yeah, but the drug is
what I use to numb it.
But the only thing it does
is get worse and worse.
- [Interviewer] What helps you survive?
Is there any personality
trait or something that--
cause this career is
not for everyone, right?
- It's not.
You'd have to have
street knowledge as well
as book knowledge.
I'm not from the streets,
but I have street knowledge.
And the more things I go through
the more I learn.
Everything in life is a lesson.
It's just, when a lesson
that repeats itself
you gotta make sure you
learn from the last one
so you don't, mess up or make
a mistake the next time around
you know how to handle the situation.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- [Trina] To be safe.
What I mean by that is,
if sexually, just make
sure you protect yourself,
make sure you have somebody to protect you
and then make sure you
can protect yourself too.
Not even saying what with
a weapon, but just with,
with not wisdom, how can I say it?
Just use your head.
Just pay attention to everything
and everyone around you.
Pay attention to how people
interact with each other.
Because if a person interacts
with a certain person
a certain way or acts a certain
way when they're not there
and then when they're
there, they act differently,
nine times out of 10,
they're going to act
the same way with you.
So, you just gotta pay
attention and be observant
- [Interviewer] In this
lifestyle where everyone is
up to something devious everyone's--
- Everybody's out to get.
- [Interviewer] No,
one's really looking out
for your best interest.
- No.
I mean, you might run across
some people who are good,
or who aren't like how everyone else is.
Cause it's a game basically.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but it
must be tough to have nobody
that's really kind of just--
- Yeah, it's tough.
But as long as you have
God first and yourself,
you should be all right.
- [Interviewer] Are you religious?
- I'm a Christian.
Yeah, I believe in God.
- [Interviewer] Does
that help you survive?
- I feel like God kept me,
he's protected me in a lot of situations.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- Best time of my life?
I wanna say my 19th birthday.
I went on a trip to Hawaii to Maui.
And it was just, the ora
the energy, the vibes,
the air, the environment
everything is just,
it was like paradise, it was peaceful.
It's like, I never wanted to leave.
- [Interviewer] What was
the worst time in your life?
- When I started doing drugs.
Because doing drugs led to other
things and to other people.
So, I would never got caught
up in the lifestyle I'm in
had I never started doing drugs.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you're addicted
to this lifestyle?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] It's not just the drugs.
- It's the lifestyle.
I mean, I'm out here by choice
not because I have to.
I have a house, I have car,
I have pretty much everything
I could need or want,
but I just, it's materialistic.
I can get it.
As quick as I get it is
as quick as I can lose it.
As I can lose it as quick
as I can get it again.
- [Interviewer] And getting
a square job is not--
- I can't answer to nobody.
I like moving on my time.
No.
I make more money, way
more money now than I did.
I used to work for the post office
and I was making good money then
but I make more on the streets.
- [Interviewer] What's the worst thing
that's happened to you?
Working the streets?
- Somebody I was dating at the time had--
he smoked, he smoked cocaine and he had a,
I call it a crack attack
and he thought I was
hiding drugs in my pussy.
So, he basically went to the left on me.
We're sitting in the back of my truck,
one of his homegirls was driving.
His other friend was in the passenger seat
and me and him were in the back.
And yeah, basically he
stripped me down naked
stuck his fingers in me
to see if I was hiding drugs in there.
And he did it to the point
where I started bleeding.
Then he kicked me out my car
onto the streets naked and drove off.
I've been set up by
people I was dealing with.
I've been kidnapped,
I've been held hostage,
I've been raped, I've been robbed,
I've been through it all
but yet I'm still in it.
- If this is the lifestyle I wanna live
I have to accept everything
that comes with it.
I don't have to accept it,
but I just have to be
aware and be prepared.
Cause it's it's bound to happen.
- [Interviewer] What is
your years on the streets
taught you about human nature?
- Mm, human nature.
Basically, people are in
it for the benefit of them.
And once you don't benefit them no more,
it's like you don't
matter, you don't exist.
You can be replaced.
It's the four Fs.
They find you, they
feed you, they fuck you
and then they forget you.
Sometimes it's just three
cause they might not feed you.
But they'll find you, they'll fuck you
and they damn sure will forget you.
- [Interviewer] Have you seen the limits
of what you'll do for money
changing over the years?
- Yes.
Cause in the beginning
soliciting myself was never an option,
but once I got deeper into the lifestyle,
especially with drugs being involved
and being in fucked up situations,
if somebody offers you
some money or some drugs
or whatever and you know whatever it is
that they want and for you to receive that
it's only gonna last, it's
only gonna take a few minutes,
so it's just like, fuck it.
Let me just go ahead and do this.
It's degrading in the beginning.
But after a while, it's
just like, whatever.
It just becomes a habit.
- [Interviewer] What words
would you give to a young girl
who's thinking about
doing something like this?
- You'll never find any
fulfillment or anything you want
or that'll make you happy in the streets.
Not from a man, not from a dog, a cat,
a bird, whatever.
And if anybody ever offers you drugs,
especially somebody who's
supposed to care about you,
they're not for you
because you never bring
a demon like that to
somebody that you love.
And somebody that I thought loved me.
I was with her for 10 years.
For 10 years.
And they said money is
the root to all evil.
And it is because, because of money
she brought this demon into
my world to control me.
And for her benefit
- [Interviewer] And now you
feel like you're a slave to it?
- At times yes.
Sometimes I think, Oh, I got it.
I'm in control, but we are not in control.
We're powerless to this.
I'm powerless.
- [Interviewer] All right, Trina.
Well, thank you for coming
in and talking with me
and good luck with
wherever you go from here.
You're still really young.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You've got lots of time
to straighten out your life.
- Yes I do.
- [Interviewer] And you're wise too.
- Yes I am.
- [Interviewer] You see what you're doing?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right,
thank you very much.
- Thank you.